(audience clapping)
All right and we have Tan Bower.
Hi Tan.
Hi. And Hi Y'all, hi family.
Hi.
So, it's gonna be a dare,
are you ready for this?
Okay, yes.
Drew, I would like you to put red lipstick
on Rossi Ross.
(Ross laughing)
Oh, you're gonna bring out my natural beauty huh?
It'll go with your shirt.
Pucker up buttercup.
Like how do I do it, like this?
Or like stretch out?
Here this way.
Okay.
No you gotta switch with me.
Okay?
Yeah, that's better.
Oh that's it, thank you.
Okay, you need lighting, okay.
Okay now just don't move.
Why not do it this way and then we'll do a reveal?
Okay, and then tilt your head down.
Okay.
Okay, perfect.
No, it's so hard not to talk.
You're moving.
Chin down.
How long does this take?
Do you want me to get it right?
I do, I do, I do.
(audience laughing)
(Lips smacking)
Perfect?
Yes.
Okay, are you ready?
Yes, yes.
Okay, count me in, count me in Drew.
One, two, three.
(Audience cheering and laughing)
I just saw myself, I just saw myself.
(Ross sighing)
What you're witnessing
is the birth of my new signature look. Hello?
Fabulous.
I do like it.
Rossi, I think you look really pretty.
Yeah, okay. I look, yeah.
You did a good job, you did a good job.
I did do a good job.
You did do a good job.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
Tan, what gave you the idea to do this?
So my daughter and I love makeup, Aurora, she's 14.
Of course she's into makeup right now, so.
Well, could I put a little basket
of Flower Beauty together for you guys?
I would love that, I would love that.
Okay, that's done, I'll get it to you after the show.
Well thank you everybody for choosing
to spend your time with us.
We make this show for you so
take it with you.
Take it with you.
(audience clapping)
(upbeat music)